Now, I think we have one more call.
Okay, Darren had a question. I hope it's
sincere. If he's another guy, because
this picture is scaring me. He's got a
picture of a pig. He's got a picture of
Muhammad stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> Hello. Good night.
>> I can't hear you.
>> Hello.
>> Yes.
>> Good night.
>> Blessings of God on you and your
daughters. I hope you keep keep on doing
what you're doing because you help a lot
of people.
>> God bless you.
>> And also
>> glory to the Holy Spirit in Jesus name.
I couldn't tell from your accent was
strong. Sorry about that, brother. Go
ahead. What was your question? But you
had have your Bible ready, right?
>> Yeah. So, so, so last week I was in a
debate. I will take it slow because I'm
accent, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, last week I was someone asked me a
question, right? And the question was,
if we die and go to heaven or hell
immediately, then what is the sense for
having a judgment day? And the way I
answered it was John 3:18. So I wanted
to know,
>> yeah, I answered that last night,
brother. Brother, I answered. And those
who tell you that shows they're
ignorant. The reason why we're going to
be judged. Those in heaven know they're
not going to hell, right?
>> Yeah. So when they come to be judged,
it's not to determine where they will
dwell. They know they're with Christ.
It's to then determine their ranks
because then the Lord's going to give
them a ri life review and every deed
they've done, they'll be rewarded or
lose a reward to determine their ranks
because Jesus said some will be great in
the kingdom, some will be least.
Okay, that's number one. The people who
are in Hades,
they know that when they stand before
the Lord, they're going to go to hell in
their bodies, not just their souls.
That's Matthew 10:28. In Matthew 10:28,
Jesus says, "Do not be afraid of the one
who can destroy the body. Kill the body,
but not the soul." So that tells you the
soul's not the same as the body. Because
if I kill your body, and your body is
your soul, and your soul is you, then I
kill your soul, too. Right.
>> Correct. But he says there are those who
kill your body but can't kill your soul.
Rather fear the one who can destroy both
body and soul
in hell. So at the end of the day your
souls come out of Hades if you're an
unbeliever. You'll be united to your
bodies and then God will show you why
you deserve everlasting destruction
because he's going to give you a life
review. So right now imagine, let me
give you a scene. You've been arrested
by the police for murder. and you're
locked up in a prison, but you haven't
been sentenced yet. So, why are you in
prison? Because you're in prison, so you
don't escape. Waiting your trial when
the judge then passes sentence and
throws you back in prison. See how that
works?
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> So, when those are in Hades, they know
they're going to face God and judgment
and be destroyed with everlasting
destruction. But they'll be told why.
Just like you're in prison, you're
waiting to go before the judge. So the
judge tells you what your crime is and
why you deserve the punishment and once
you receive the senting sentencing
sentencing off you go. That's a very
stupid objection. And the people who
think it's smart good objection, they're
pathetic because it's bad. Hope that
answered your question, brother. I don't
know if it did.
>> Yeah, it does. And um well, this week we
going to more go uh more in depth into
it. And your session on the rich man and
Lazarus really important in helping me
with
>> Amen. understanding about the par about
the parable because they just assume if
it's a parable is not um actual
>> say even if they say parable say I
challenge you show me a parable in the
Bible that's not based on reality
meaning isn't it true that every parable
that Jesus gives is based on actual
everyday reality like a farmer plants
seed isn't that real
>> so Jesus never uses a parable that's not
based on reality right
No, I'm not
>> like Alice in Wonderland. Alice goes
down the hole. That's fantasy, right?
>> Yeah, that is fantasy.
>> But when Jesus gives you a parable, it's
based on everyday real life phenomenon
that people engage in like farmers do
plant seeds, right? Some of the seed
falls on rocky soil that happens. So
he's taking actual experiences to make
points. Therefore, that means we should
expect that when he talks about the
afterlife, that's based on how the
afterlife actually exists. Because in
every parable, he uses everyday actual
real life phenomenon to make a point.
>> All right?
>> So then where do they get that in Luke
16:1 19-1? It's a parable meaning it's
not real. All his parables are based on
reality.
>> Yeah. Well, that argument was one I was
going to use. I didn't really think
about it from before, but now to think
about it, when I look at your session, I
say, "But Psalms make plenty sense." You
know, you say, "No, ask
the same as them."
>> No, ask him. Say, "Can you show me one
of Jesus parables was not based on
everyday phenomenon. A sewer plants
seed, his enemy plants seed because he
hates him." Well, that happened. Or a
rich man or a man rents out his his
vineyard. that happened back then and
hired tenants. That was things that
actually happened. So Jesus doesn't
quote parables that are not based on
everyday reality observable phenomenon.
That means when he talks about the
afterlife, that has to be a reflection
of how the afterlife is.
>> True,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> So hope that clear. I don't know if that
answered the question.
>> Yeah, that answers the question. But
honestly, the people that are debating
it with is really foolish because once
said that um the the bottomless pit is
on earth and the devil be bound to earth
and just show that they don't even read
the Bible but they're trying to act like
they know the Bible and just
>> even Satan reads the Bible but he twists
it. So don't waste your time. If you've
answered them, they want to debate.
Don't waste your time. Just pray for
them. Ignore them.
>> Don't waste their time. You're not You
don't make people Christians. The Holy
Spirit does. And the Holy Spirit says be
discerning. If someone keeps arguing, if
someone keeps fighting and twisting your
words, then now move on. Have nothing to
do with them. Neither Jesus nor the
apostles would keep debating people for
the sake of debate. They would refute
them and if they didn't accept, they
moved on and walked away and didn't
waste their time with them.
>> Makes sense.
>> All right, brother.
>> Yeah. Thanks.
>> Any other questions? Are you okay?
>> No, okay.
>> Okay. Now, you sound like you you're uh
are you from Jamaica? Ireie. I man
>> Trinidad.
>> Many. Hold on, man. Hold on. We got a
party now, man. Wait a second, man. No
more questions. You're okay.
>> Is that
>> Do you have more questions or you're
done?
>> No, I don't. I know.
>> Okay, don't leave yet. Hold on, man.
Because you and me going to me go to
party, man. Ian,
what's up, man? Hold on, man. Yan. Yan.
Cha. Yan. What's up, man? Shaba. Hi,
everyone. What's up, man? You know,
unfortunately, Trinidad.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Eased from Trinidad.
>> Yeah. I'm sorry. Please don't tell
people he's from Trinidad. Deny him. Say
he's an alien that some dogs from a
planet planted him in my land, but we
have nothing to do with that magnet.
Okay. Sha Shaman.
You know what? Before I was walking with
Jesus, I knew a man from Jamaica. He
would say Iman and then he would say
some swear words I can't repeat. I found
out later there were swear words.
>> Yeah, that's
>> you know what I'm talking about, right?
He would bring the ganja and he would
say everyone Ian and then he would say
you know it sounds like cloud right
and cloud and you combine it together. I
don't want to stir because people say
what kind of Christian are you? Yeah. I
brother anytime you have questions call
me. I'll be here for you. All right
brother.
>> Yeah. Thanks. Lord bless you, buddy.
Take care.
>> God bless you. All right, we're done,
guys.
[Music]